nah I actually don't like tattoos that
hurt
I like to really love it I just like it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
first a two-team fan just physically
what it sounds like
team families so young baby you and I
got this tattoo
how old no I never told my mother I
never tell her so I did yeah I was I was
too young to get a tattoo but I got it
it's still my favorite tattoos to this
day you know
mm just I've never got a redone I never
got a retouch token I like that is
always Kepler ridging my next tattoo was
until about like seven years later
eighteen years old and I got my next
tattoo so they let you know how old I
was
I got this except to attend one night
the dumbest thing ever in my life it was
a star right here I got the big star but
it was it was a empty star at first it
was an empty star and then I got a name
in the tattoo but then after the name
about the name cover and then I got the
cover covered put another star and then
I got that star covered another stops my
god I accepted tattoos in the same spot
I would talk it was the worst pain ever
my whole life my first set of stars I
got was I did about this I'm a little
going things ahead
[Music]
after I got that my next attack was on
my head with another star start with a
music note in it it's a lot of music but
I never like actually dig music love
music migration playing piano and drones
and stuff like that
this is the most painful tattoo I ever
received
if you notice I got tattoos repetitively
like everywhere else like you can see
it's like he got it there and there and
there so it kind of hurt that bad
there's no rails well I don't know what
was going on that day or if you had a
bad day one of me but he took all this
[ __ ] anger out on me and I'm never
ever getting in touch of everything this
right here it's a sweet man flawed later
as we play right here I got the smoke
going up it was supposed to be like an
airplane but it started hurting too much
I said I stopped at the time life was a
little rough so whenever I smoke is just
like I have the energy like I'm saying
like I just stopped thinking about the
bad [ __ ] and that makes you happy no man
whatever it was
get up and get it done no sense so the
no-smoking off lot later so it can't be
true I mean I'll fly yeah yeah then I'll
just add gone with the weed theme and I
got like the bone right here of course
every day I wish maybe smoke right now
but you know then the road tracing I
don't want the FBI run in the hair [ __ ]
scared of his guys this much that his
back was music and money of course the
vegetables are backwards for a long time
laid before I made the song shot clean
as I advanced for the back wall says
they had to eight packs a lot of people
don't know about that right there bro no
story time with that I got I actually do
this tattoo myself it's the original in
the boys logo was the cross with the
wings in it
it's a 1738 boys I did well I'll be oh
[Music]
yeah my face I forgot I need a mirror
something I don't know what that witch
was right hey what's this stars all
right so just the three stars this would
be lit the grid Massey and me it's three
stars we start this together no I'm
saying this was like the beginning
foundation this time but all started at
what us do right there then you got the
zoo gang of course again cuz I gotta let
you know who the boss is no sensors
right here
I believe they say rgf on this side
that's the camp RJ I'm saying
yeah actually staff a real good fellas
we changed it once we start again a
little bit of money is really good for
this 1730's on this side Lisa and of
course that's you know I mean that was
17:30 was my second fees to my first one
was the Black Codes house my grandpa you
know I mean then I got the Red Cross and
my other grandpa died and be home while
I'm here it's my surname again eating
caramel oh and I got his birthday on
this side and I have my daughter named
Vera and what else is up here
Tomica Georgians had it right there
supposed to be a Jersey didn't make it
hurt too much so we only got to draw it
in the 23 yeah and I love Georges no
saying that's like my favorite person in
the world but never met him yet so I
kind of don't like one of me too because
I don't like a little girl I'm saying
I heard seven different stories about
Michael Jordan and they're always bad
like it was never like it was never a
good one like it was like I'm in like in
leaves chillin it was like I met Mike he
was either took a little pretty with no
board oh no I did it gonna work out so
you know saying hopefully was door day
and be like hey Thomas middle oh I only
want to be tulips they're just pipes and
just a case yeah show did he see this
don't say it so shop tomorrow
[Music]